yeah what's up guys my name is cute hi
my name is Troy
hi my name's Leah hi my name is Ferran
and today we're trying cheap vs.
expensive lotions why is lotions so
important for people because we get a
she is you know how they say black don't
crack it's because of lotion so we have
to moisturize to stay looking so young
I'm 52 years old you wouldn't know that
because I put lotion for me my skin
dries out a lot and going outside I can
feel the tightness on my skin and it
feels like really uncomfortable yeah
like if you're in the East Coast like
once it gets dry you'll notice like in
LA I don't really get ashy back home if
I'll like even miss a spot on my body
I'll go I'm like not as much as I should
have because people they definitely
giving you that look love because I grew
up in Florida so it's oh yeah so you
walk outside adjusting a natural motion
yeah but when it gets dry it's a wrap
this is dry around the fingers around
the feet on the elbows I can't be going
out looking you know what a vampire like
the light hits the vampire and then you
turn it to yeah that's what you know
what else this is the real reason why
you don't want to do it because scary no
this is the real reason it's like if you
go to school
Ashi if you go anywhere Ashi that's you
and if you got friends around you
they're going to roast you like you're
not gonna make it I was like let's do
this one so we are doing shea moisture
it's a black one brand and never use
their body lotion though so this will be
a first time for me yeah yeah I actually
put some in my hair today did you yeah -
oh but it's like it smells good well
we're here today thanks mommy smell it
it smells great Shea Moisture sounds
fancy
coconut and hibiscus body lotion with
song mean mushroom smell I just got
perfume oh yeah
I can be out here rocking perfume and
stuff your smoke really nice does food
I'm gonna start with my problem spot
which is my elbow I can't really ever
seem to get that get that thing right
you know I'm not gonna lie this is weird
never mind
I'm gonna say it now this wasn't my
ex-girlfriend I think she's the weirdest
I didn't know but now I think I know
that's kind of weird
this is the cheap stuff
good I was expecting like a cheap legs
really Jergens like 99 and might just
beat me but this is still dry oh yeah
it's not too shiny on your hands though
but it does feel like a heavy coat now
we're gonna try this mid price lunch
little income that's the that's the
fancy stuff natural royal body new
tricks Lancome magnifique but you know
you said that so what I've studied
French and I honestly you had me sold
those I don't know if you're gonna like
this one you're smaller
well I was like an old lady kind of
maybe I like that I don't know anything
about Lancome but I think I've seen
Lancome magnifique in like Zombieland
like the first Amelie movie Ali enough
I've like he said that in the movie now
just I thought it was so funny is that
perfume I'm thinking Lancome magnifique
yeah I don't know not into this looks
like I look greasy there's a way to
shiny you gotta rub it it's almost like
it has this this thing has glitter in it
oh wow oh my god this smells expensive
yeah this smells good this smells like
something like a celebrity would put on
their body you know or somebody's
grandma my grandma specifically this
smells like my grandma
I miss her as well oh my god it says
every Lawson's gonna remind me of
somebody
what is that gonna remind you of though
like Rihanna goddamn cash I mean it's
doing the job yeah look like I've put
like but if I had to choose order right
now between this one in this one I'm
about 50 bucks 50 bucks it's not bad
what hey save your money yeah don't do
it
could you this shape don't do it don't
do it oh absolutely not
whoa absolutely not really what's well
grandpa gettin oh my god - she gave
everybody money and a birthday not me
everybody get miss so if there's
something that's above this one then I
don't even know what you guys are giving
us next because when I see this in the
story I just go nope I'm expecting some
big things out of this gold box I don't
even know what it is like a butterfly on
the top no we're gonna try the most
expensive one this looks fancy now this
one apparently is Kim Kardashian's
favorite lotion what I wore shorts and I
rolled up my shirt so I can put as much
as this of this on my body as possible
cuz I'm soaking up I like that I like
the presentation is there oh yeah it
comes with the spoon or that's amazing
it's a wand so you can really get the
lotion in oh really I don't know what I
just those like a massager an applicator
what is that do you put you scoop it out
and then you just do you rub it in like
this like a butter knife right is that
what we're doing I don't know what I'm
not worthy of music now
right yeah this one or two D and Perry
Allah dude this is some fancy words I'm
not but you're on TV so we're not about
to do that
oh I didn't even know I'm gonna or
cheese or chew them figure out clearly
Carrie I mean it looks like this looks
rich this does look rich could you
imagine you just wake up every morning
like that but honestly I feel like I
wouldn't like want to do that like when
I wake up I want to be I want to get
feel good but I want to be down and
dirty with it this is too cute I'm gonna
be the only exit it does
look at the [ __ ] on the level that you
gotta go that is pretty nice oh yeah
yeah this is the gotta this is for
surely this is it rich get it him a
bullet wound you think I'm a lotion my
whole body in the middle with that how
about this can you put like a couple of
dots on my face and then work around yes
see it's like Zen does it really okay
[Music]
let's share germs I did rub butter on my
body this is what I feel I don't want to
say that it has a consistency of almost
like a Lube oh yeah that's not bad it's
like it's very silky feels good on your
face a little more because if that's 50
I wanna say like with this whole
presentation they trying to be fancy
with it okay
Kim Kardashian this one's 50 150 $200 to
300
it's all nice but the presentation they
trying to sell us on something oh yeah
this supposed to be a full-on experience
so I'm gonna guess she probably pays
$2,000 for this lotion that's my guess I
was gonna say $100
she got my yeah listen man I'm gonna go
oh honey you think she's buying $100
lotion I feel like there's no way a
hundo sure to be more
yeah hundred dollars right okay a
thousand dollars in u.s. dollars oh no
wait what's the download No
I don't care how much money I got who
gave us tis just not in our budget it
wasn't my connection yo shout out to
y'all what is this made out of
that makes it Kim K is living a bougie
bison she really is what does Kanye
Jewish you doing this you can kanye
lotion oh he better don't you a again
like I said being a she's is not a good
look you don't want to be looking like
you stuck your hand in chalk or
something like that
[Music]